Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Antes del mundo de los humanos,
existía el de los dioses,
un reino de campos, praderas y jardines.
En este ámbito celestial,
cuatro hermanos vagaban errantes.
Como familia, no se tenían
más que el uno al otro.
Incluso desconocían
quiénes eran sus padres.
Uno de los hermanos, Deminán,
era distinto a los demás.
Tenía la piel cubierta
de dolorosas costras
y se preguntaba por qué, de todos ellos,
era el único condenado a esta afección.
Cierto día, mientras Yaya, el espíritu
supremo, se encontraba en el jardín,
Deminán y sus hermanos
entraron furtivamente a su casa.
Tras darse un festín y revisar el lugar,
vieron una gran calabaza en un rincón.
En el intento de ver su contenido,
la vasija se les cayó por accidente.
La calabaza se hizo añicos,
y surgió un torrente de agua
que arrastró a los hermanos
y los desterró para siempre
de ese reino celestial.
Las aguas que emanaron de la calabaza
formaron un nuevo mundo,
uno cubierto de mares,
inexistentes en el mundo de los dioses.
Los mares rebosaban
de peces y otras criaturas,
con islas y cuevas esparcidas por doquier.
Este mundo de mares también fue
separado de las tierras celestiales,
y los hermanos vagaron errantes,
aún más desorientados
que en su mundo anterior.
Cierto día, tres de los hermanos
encontraron una choza
habitada por un anciano llamado
Bayamanaco, quien los invitó a entrar.
Deminán llegó algo más tarde,
e ingresó también a la morada.
Bayamanaco se presentó
como el abuelo de los hermanos
y les obsequió
un pan de yuca muy especial.
El anciano les reveló su linaje familiar:
la madre había sido
la diosa Madre Tierra, Itibi Cahubaba,
quien murió al momento de parirlos.
Los hermanos le agradecieron
la hospitalidad
y el relato de su descendencia.
Pero Bayamanaco lanzó
de su nariz una mucosidad de tabaco
que acabó en la espalda de Deminán.
La piel afectada por la agresión comenzó
a inflamarse y a causarle gran ardor.
Poco después, Deminán empezó a delirar,
y tanto se agravó
la inflamación de su espalda
que los hermanos temieron por su vida.
Sin saber a qué recurrir,
le hicieron un corte en la piel.
De la incisión surgió una tortuga
que se alejó nadando,
abriéndose paso con facilidad
entre la tierra y el mar.
Cuando Deminán se recuperó del delirio,
finalmente comprendió
la maldición de su enfermedad:
era un caracaracol,
capaz de comunicarse con los dioses.
Oficiaba de nexo entre
el reino celestial y el reino terrestre.
Deminán fue el primero de
la larga estirpe de los caracaracoles.
El mundo de los mares,
surgido de la calabaza que
él y sus hermanos habían hecho trizas,
se transformó en el mundo de los humanos,
donde los caracaracoles
que siguieron a Deminán
mantuvieron un delicado equilibrio
entre los humanos y los dioses.
Pero ese poder especial tuvo su precio:
Deminán y los caracaracoles posteriores
sufrieron la maldición de esa enfermedad
que inicialmente lo había distinguido
de sus hermanos.
Representado en grabados
y estatuillas taínas
con una joroba y escuálidos brazos,
el caracaracol es tomado como bendición
y también como maldición
por intermediar entre los mundos.